[MUSIC PLAYING]
We're an app for booking
last-minute hotel rooms.
We work with hotels
that have empty rooms,
and they provide
these discounts.
We make it really easy to
book those rooms on our apps.
One of the exciting
moments was when
it was about two weeks into
the launch of Hotel Tonight
that somebody
booked, and we didn't
know who they were, It was
our first real customer.
And so we all around
the office and said,
hey, do you know this guy?
Do you know this guy?
And we all said no, and
then we said, oh my gosh,
it's a real customer.
That was a really
exciting moment.
We also had a really
big moment when we first
got our big first press hit.
So we were on the
cover of the USA Today,
and this was back when paper
newspapers were handed out
to everybody who
stayed in hotels.
So it was just a
wonderful press hit for us
that really got us out to this
great target market of people
that travel for
business all the time.
And that doubled
our growth overnight
and set a new
standard, and we just
kept on building from there.
I think one of the most
interesting aspects
of the mobile ecosystem is
that app stores have ratings.
So customers are telling
other customers whether or not
an app is high
quality, whether or not
a product's high quality.
That doesn't exist on the web.
So it's very hard for a company
with a lackluster product
to succeed.
Otherwise they're going
to get bad reviews.
No matter how much money
they put into marketing,
it's not going to be able to
get the same level of customer
acceptance that a
great product will be.
So we focus a lot on
product experience.
We focus a lot on customer
service and customer
experience and keeping
our customers happy,
and that resulted
in great ratings.
It resulted in more trial,
more awareness, more happy
customers, and it
fueled from there.
And that's a very
uniquely mobile element
that app stores are brought to
the world with these ratings
and reviews and
that feedback loop.